I was in Madison Square Gardens for the
UFC Donald Trump walks in with Kid Rock
and Dana White of course I have a
history with Kid Rock one of the most
viewed videos on my YouTube channel is
called celebrities I did with I go to
the bathroom and Kid Rock is in the
bathroom I'm like yeah what's up dude
you know like I'm just excited farthest
thing from my mind is that video and
he's like no why'd you do me like
that that's the first thing he said to
you yeah and he was like oh dude one
thing has really changed since I saw you
now I'm
rich doesn't he has a replica of a White
House house wow that's his Nashville
house right
there how gnarly is that